bonjour et bienvenue à la maison des
maternelles à votre service on est en
direct 9h55 157,9 bouger dit syncrude
sexe
ce lundi la une du magazine
d'information le times a été détournée
montrant la face cachée du président
russe tout les rues sont comme ça sent
le raconte poutine et tous les réseaux
se tient pas poutine et tous les russes
papa et son nouveau à le comparer au
dictateur hitler notamment la chanteuse
madonna qui a réalisé un clip en soutien
à l'ukraine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selon certains l'histoire se répète pour
d'autres ces gars ne sont pas
comparables la guerre a déjà poussé
500000 eux craignant fuir leur pays ils
se rendent en hongrie en moldavie en
roumanie en slovaquie et bien sûr
majoritairement en pologne où près de
trois cent mille réfugiés sont déjà
arrivés regardez cette image saisissante
une file interminable de voitures qui
arrivent du craignent en direction de la
pologne je le mettrais plus ça parce que
ça mérite pas d'être là ça vous choque
ça vous choque qu'on montre dans dans ce
studio etc pour les téléspectateurs
derrière ces story le drapeau à savoir
comment c'est le drapeau russe parce que
ça
il faut mettre voilà ce drapeau là le
jaune qui symbolise la c'est le ciel
bleu libre de tout les bombardes heures
de bombardier le ciel bleu de paix un
ciel bleu au dessus d'un champ de colza
jaune si cette photo et en partager ces
dernières heures c'est pour ses couleurs
rappelant le drapeau de l'ukraine
d'autres internautes ont trouvé des
plantes et fleurs pour dire leur soutien
aux ukrainiens comme le tournesol devenu
symbole de paix sur les réseaux sociaux
et pour cette fois la colombe a laissé
sa place à une maison joe plumage
bicolore
je fais comme
l'oiseau
sa vie vers muret l'eau fraîche
oui effectivement je pense qu'on peut
sans problème le comparer mais pas des
concentrations avec une question lui va
pas se suicider ah oui il va pas se
suicider à ce tracé sur sql pour avoir
des
commandes et en français mais bien se
relancer
on n'est pas voter si siens
faisons un petit jeu si je vous dis
crébillon valseuses olive de poissy
roubignolles tu vas y deviner de quoi je
parle et oui tous ces petits noms que
l'on doit à rabelais renvoie aux
testicules les bijoux de famille fascine
et ce depuis bien longtemps du latin
testis il signifie de témoins un
ukrainien rond-point des soldats russes
vous êtes en panne les gars ouais de
gasoil un coup de main on vous ramène en
russie
elle change sur réaliste se poursuit
l'ukrainien en plaisantant à nouveau dix
ans aux soldats qu'ils ne sont pas les
seuls à être perdu cette autre vidéo
montre selon ses auteurs un tracteur rue
craignent en venant en aide un blanc des
russes apparemment en panne des images
qui témoignent des difficultés
grandissantes des russes sur le terrain
belle équipe de droit cassé à ce premier
je peux vous dire que on est sur le haut
du panier de pâte dans plusieurs
civilisations antiques seuls les hommes
avaient le droit de témoigner devant les
tribunaux
et pour prouver leur virilité il devait
prêter serment non pas en levant la main
mais en la posant sur leurs bourses il
faut dire que ces deux petites boules
rondes d'environ 20 grammes sont
essentiels pour ces messieurs en plus
des spermatozoïdes elles produisent la
testostérone à la puberté cette hormone
apporte notamment les poils sur le
manteau les gros muscles et la doua
grave je posais cette question que je
n'imaginais jamais posé sur un plateau
de télévision une attaque nucléaire est
elle possible en france on en est là et
on en est là pourquoi parce qu'à 15
heures hier la déclaration me
semble-t-il de vladimir poutine a agi
comme une déflagration et chacun pu le
mesurer
d'abord dans son entourage familial dans
son entourage a big al jabri sonné dans
un cauchemar faut qu'on pense qu'on
réveille c'est pas possible je vois bien
ce que fait la nuit à poutine je le
connais pour l'avoir si je puis dire
pratique et là il est en train de de
créer un climat pour faire peur pour
impressionner d'où la menace nucléaire
dont il sait pas ce que c'est double
dont il sait bien sûr dont il sait vous
pensez que c'est du bluff oui bien sûr
que c'est du bluff une attaque nucléaire
sur une ville comme paris quelles sont
les conséquences rien détruite par paris
et détruit paris détruits et c'est à
dire on ne parle pas de halte à dire
qu'est ce que vous appelez détruit tout
est détruit c'est il ya plus rien vous
rappeler les photos d'hiroshima c'est
hiroshima détruire ces bandelettes et
100 fois moins puissante que les bons
qui pourrait être déployé sur paris
c'est là
c'est ma fête service car on
n'était pas aussi
en fait il sait parfaitement que s'il
devait utiliser l'armé nucléaire il y
aurait en réponse une réaction
américaine une réaction de tous les pays
qui disposent de la force de dissuasion
en europe c'est à dire la france et le
royaume uni une réaction qui serait
extrêmement forte et qui engendrerait
des dégâts considérables cette image qui
a fait le tour du monde celle d'une
ukrainienne réfugier dans le métro de
kiev qui a donné naissance à une petite
fille et finalement c'est l'un des rares
événements heureux du week-end il ya un
gars qui m'appelle je vous jure que
c'est vrai et qui me dit il faudrait
qu'on parte en russie a longtemps et à
3,4 ou mais il faudrait qu'on parte en
russie que tu partes avec moi parce que
en fait il ya un mec qui proche de
vladimir poutine qui voudrait que tu
amènes teddy riner
je crois que c'est vrai
elle va s'imposer en patronne derrière
de l'attitude de lolita sur hello hello
t elle à la tête basse et les somistes
voilà voilà
elle va même pas servir de ses corners
pour regardes tu auras yen recule devant
le lycée
c'est impressionnant perdent ils
voudraient que tu fasses à l'acte
organise un petit truc avec teddy riner
est lui un genre qu'ils fassent un petit
combat genre comme ça une petite et une
petite 'le une trace est rude tous les
deux jours que c'est vrai il ya dit
voilà il vous le voudrez ça c'est son
rêve absolu c'est vraiment son rêve
absolu s'il pense qu'à ça ils pensent
qu'au judo dans le reste de l'actualité
c'est la guerre certes mais ça n'empêche
pas certains de prendre du plaisir et
dans la cour de l'elysée en plus et bien
le pourrait complètement rabattre les
cartes de la présidentielle à en croire
françois hollande qui s'est exprimé il
ya quelques minutes la symétrie que je
fais c'est dans la cour de l'elysée
ceci dit elle a raison elle fait la mer
pourrait pas la guerre et c'est très
bien comme ça bon il ya un débat sur
bouillonnant il faut reporter la
sélection présidentielle non je t'assure
et cissé je viens de tizé didier giraud
te tue attisé autre chose ce soir au
stand du gers
mots d'enfants mot pluriel le tirage
des b à c o n pu y a c'est
caca boudin c'est ça exactement quels
cas bouddha alors une salle caca boudin
entre 3 4 ans et 6 7 ans si ça persiste
à 20 ans c'est un petit peu embêtant